这次我们认识下HANA服务器端的JavaScript（xsjs）
在SP05中，XSJS主要用来显示HANA中的数据
到外部系统或者用户界面上
SP05中，XSJS的主要用于在HANA中处理数据
还有如并行更新计算和逻辑控制等功能
SP06提供了HTTP出站请求新功能
这个特性将HANA变成一个“数据消费者”
使我们可以调用并获取其他系统的数据
这种机制用来捕获数据并保存在HANA数据库中
在某种程度上利用外部服务等创建混合网站，
来提供查找，验证数据等服务。
也可以很方便地使用它来调用ABAP应用系统
消费ABAP或JAVA应用中的数据并存到HANA中
我想给你们展示两个应用场景
第一个是在ABAP上创建一个简单RESTFulf服务来暴露数据
然后用XSJS调用Web服务并保存数据到HANA数据库中
第二个例子展示混搭应用
使用简单免费的"国会图片检索"web服务
我将会给你展示如何使用HANA访问这上面的数据
通过检索并将HANA中数据和图片一并显示在页面上
第一个要演示是从ABAP中消费数据
为了展示我用无状态的BSP在ABAP中创建一个简单的web服务
这是个好且简单地创建web服务的方式。。。来看下它的逻辑。。
用OnInitialization方法
创建了一个基于JSON的Writer对象
还创建了一个小的类zcl_user包含方法get_details
它接受username为输入参数
用username查找用户详细信息并返回用户地址
get_details只是用调用BAPI来获取用户数据并返回地址
如果有错误就在BAPI里抛出详细异常信息
然后我只是把ABAP地址格式转换成JSON格式
默认情况下，转换是输入二进制格式
通过Writer对象转换成文本格式
lv_json就是字符串类型的
这样就输出了JSON字符串
如果有错误发生，将返回的对象也转换成JSON格式
并设置HTTP状态码为500，返回错误消息
如果你谙熟ABAP，你可能已经嗅到了不一样
那是因为我用的是ABAP 740的版本
隐式类型定义，可以直接转换或返回为左边定义的类型
#符号通过下标来访问内部表中的记录
看不懂的话也不要迷茫
这些只是ABAP 740中新的，好的语法而已
这些新语法并不是这次视频的目的，ABAP仅是作为例子
来创建web服务，并且被HANA调用
棒极了
为了测试让我在浏览器中打开
复制粘贴web服务地址到浏览器中
加上username
username=jungth
返回了JSON格式数据，包含了用户的详细信息
web服务建好了，下面让我们在HANA中来轻松地访问这些数据
如果你看过CDS这个视频，那里我创建了一个用户表
让我们快速的回顾下这张表
表包含PERS_NO, FIRSTNAME, LASTNAME 和EMAIL字段
这些字段正是我们从ABAP web服务中拉过来的
而且表里也没有数据。
现在让我们写一个小的JS脚本
脚本执行会从ABAP系统中查询并拉取用户详细信息
并保存到HANA数据库中的User表里
我应该提示下这个HANA系统，
为了这个演示，我的说它和ABAP系统没有关系
虽然理论上ABAP是运行在HANA数据库上的
为了演示，我们的假设ABAP和HANA是两个独立的系统
HANA可以作为独立的系统存在（数据库+系统）
我们通过SLT，BOBJ把数据从ABAP上移到HANA数据库中
然而通过另外一种方式，你甚至可以调用BAdI，更新ABAP系统上的数据
还有更多的可能性，比如访问ABAP系统中业务逻辑等
这里我们故意简化这个例子来达到学习的目的
在我调用web服务之前
我需要一个新的对象来定义ABAP上web服务目标
现在创建一个后缀为xshttpdest的文件
打开service文件夹，创建新文件
文件名为 user.xshttpdest
为了演示，我已经准备好了，你也不想看我码字，我们来看内容
基本上你需要提供主机host
端口号port来建立http连接
目标连接的描述description
路径前缀pathPrefix
pathPrefix上甚至包含了输入的参数username
我可以在代码中提供pathPrefix之后的所有内容
我只是想简化例子，它需要做的就是解析username的值
如果有多个参数的话，我就不会这个干了
在后面的代码里你会看到
指定身份验证类型的authType
这个例子里web服务不需要用户验证
也许不是个现实的场景
尤其是关于用户信息的web服务，但是作为例子却能很容易地展示
我可以用BASIC验证方式弹出用户登陆框
在xhttpdest中也可以很容易的维护用户名和密码来验证
但为了简化这个例子，这里没有用户验证
这个例子也没有用到Proxy因为ABAP系统在同一个防火墙内
保存xshttpdest并激活
我可以用快捷键或者工具栏上的激活按钮来激活
但我已经习惯了右击菜单来激活
下一步就是在代码中用这个xshttpdest文件
让我来创建一个新服务，取名为User.xsjs
复制粘贴，你应该不想看我敲代码
我们来过一遍
首先执行很简单，没有任何参数输入
我可以检查一下用户名是否合法，但作为例子，还是简单点好
进入方法内，用httprequest对象来获取username
你总得解析username并获取到那个用户的信息
在真实场景中，我可能先获取到所有的用户
然后从ABAP循环请求每一个用户详细信息
但作为例子，我们保持简单(KISS)
下一步创建一个http destination对象
用新的API,$.net.http.readDestination
把xshttpdest路径传给方法
改为我的仓库路径sp06.services
xshttpdest的名字是user作为第二个参数
创建Http Client和WebRequest实例并调用
Http Method是GET
唯一的参数是username字符串
还记得我在path中设置username=
所以这里是直接把username附加到路径上
req和dest作为参数调用client.request方法，得到响应
这里我们拿到响应主体中的数据
查看请求响应状态
把我们这个服务的响应状态设置为当前请求的响应状态
这里也检查状态，如果有服务异常
拿到异常详细信息并解析为JSON对象
因为ABAP返回的是JSON字符串
所以很容易被JSON.parse解析成JS对象
response.setBody设置响应内容
我可以用JS下标访问ABAP内部表ITAB
取到下标为0的MESSAGE字段并输出
JSON(其实是JS)非常容易的访问嵌套结构的对象
ABAP结构或内部表转换成JSON字符串就很容易被XSJS访问
如果ABAP服务没有异常发生
当然现实中要检查服务异常，不过作为例子(KISS)
然后解析响应主体，并保存到数据库，设置响应主体消息
一条消息称用户xxx已被保存
这里没啥新内容，语法和sp05一样
我只是建立了一个Query对象，UPSET语句来保存到数据库
这里用了预编译语句以防止SQL注入
因为这里数据来自外部，但我信任这些数据
我可以用userDet来访问ABAP服务返回的用户数据
最后保存到数据库中
因为用的是UPSET语句，故不存在时保存，存在时更新
万事俱备了
激活
现在可以来测试一下服务
打开游览器，输入正确的地址
加上URL参数username=GUNGTH
验证用户
成功显示响应信息“用户xxx已经被保存”
如果想验证数据是否保存，可以去表中直接查看
同样的，再测试另一个，成功保存
最后如果输入非法的用户名JUNK
得到消息说：JUNK不存在
简单的例子阐释了一个系统集成的场景
XSJS不仅可以暴露数据，也可以调用其他服务来获取数据
再来一个例子
这次我要调用的是一个完全外部服务
国会图片检索（Congress Image Search）
再来创建一个xshttpdest文件
取名image.xshttpdest
设置host为www.loc.gov，端口为80
pathPrefix已经设置成输出为JSON格式
你也可以看到我设置了query参数q=
这个例子也没有验证
但服务器不在SAP防火墙内，所以设置了代理服务器
这就是xshttpdest文件
现在创建一个XSJS文件Images.xsjs
复制粘贴代码，searchImages方法需要两个URL参数
一个需要在图片库中检索的关键字
另一个是索引，因为返回的JSON会包含多个图片
而我只想显示某个图片
如果索引没有在URL中定义，则默认显示第一个
创建的xshttpdest就跟以前的一样
sp6.services为路径，images是xshttpdest名字
就像上个例子中建立的查询字符串一样
把req和dest作为参数调用HTTP请求
依然拿到JSON格式的响应主体
首先检查响应状态，如果有错就返回获取到的错误信息
为了演示，解析错误信息并输出没大碍
如果没有错误，我实际上写了一小段HTML来输出
首先解析返回内容，显示目前是第几张图片
然后把返回的图片URL用于img标签中
这儿我能用下标index访问返回解析过的JS对象
.imge.full来访问完整的图片地址
保存这两个文件并激活
现在可以来测试这个服务了
在浏览器中输入正确的地址
用New York作为关键字来查询
一共找到95960条关于New York的图片
现在默认显示的是第一张图片
如果想查看某张特殊的图片
用下标index=3查看第三张图片
额，有意思，来看第6张
当然也能更改查询关键字
我，我，我想看米老鼠。。。
额，第一张竟然没有数字化。。。
我要给我儿子看米老鼠
现在你知道怎样创建一个混搭程序
服务是由Congress维护的，开放的图片库
也可以绑定其他服务到我的应用中
这个例子非常简单，只是获取到图片地址并显示
可以想象，在较大的应用的绑定这个图片检索服务
甚至ebay，Google，或者任意多的，可访问的HTTP服务
创建一个真正混搭应用,混合HANA和互联网数据
也可以执行外部逻辑，由于仅是数据获取和展示
也可以触发或更新另外一个系统上的数据等
HANA和它的核心真正地打开了所有的可能